welcome to this video we're solid yet
another 15 minute game I i had done
recorded three games from the Christmas
days already and all those games yeah
well it's a bit short excluding me a bit
short so I play add an additional game
and now I get a somewhat higher rated
opponent 21 something he's saying he's
playing his first I am hard to believe
with this rating he's got a relatively
new rating at fifteen-minute chest the
other rating song on lower so let's see
how he how he fares Bishop f5 had a
sister this somewhat round and ambitious
or c5 is probably right mercy for of
course sorry yellow I'm amber I was
thinking about the groom felt this is
basically room filled with colors
reversed and down I of course being
white having an additional tempo so I
was this was why I was talking about c5
um ok well just here
boy he knows my channel yeah I'm telling
me some video yeah let's see okay yeah
now i'm i'm running out of useful moves
so I'm I mean useful this is useful one
but then I mean preparation moves let's
see should I take now on 1c5 this is the
tirage with Bishop f5 and Bishop f5 is
really strange for the tirage defense to
the Queens gambit yeah okay I'll take
it's difficult now for him not to
recapture other if made it is simply
doesn't I thought you should really
recapture there's more than one
promising with known ID for for example
or Bishop e3 we are Bishop e3 is the
simplest one just just keeping the pond
it's not clear how he is going to to get
it back I mean a move like Queen a five
I can just take d5 if everything else
fails
yeah maybe this way but if I just play a
three and before isn't this just keeping
the pawn mm yeah well I'll just I just
go for that I can be really greedy
okay well how does he prevent that I
don't see it you can play a five but
then I mean Eve night a form i can just
protect this pawn yeah I'll cover it
this is an important pawn not it's not
just the material gain but also the
important squares it controls and three
against two on the queenside is very
useful as well okay this is a bit bit
annoying yeah i forgot that rupee one
it's not possible but i can i can play
that means and this should help to
clarify matters i'm attacking the bishop
on 85 so after a bab he cannot take on
before because he needs to attend to
this this Bishop first and taking on d4
i'm just going to recapture with the
bishop and then everything's very nicely
protected
Jim I don't know yambol not to move you
you love to make but what else yeah this
now is a very nice configuration the
knight on c3 puts pressure on d5 the
bishop puts pressure on d5 and while the
bishop on d4 is just ideally placed yeah
I can just take it yeah this is some
simplest yeah keep it simple no need to
to do anything fancy here and to not
quite sure but probably this is a good
one the potential passer will be on the
C file b5 c6 not immediately probably
because there's III hanging but i think
the rook is well placed on the sea fowl
I could have also taken on only four but
I don't really see that that this is
necessary yet mmm 3b three would have
been an interesting alternative actually
intending rook to d1 now this was maybe
even better
yeah not much choice I don't really want
to retreat the rook and f4 is just ugly
yeah not even that is so terrible but
not not necessary at all I can just keep
it tidy everything protected kind of the
kind of play some not much that I can do
him
yeah I think I really I shouldn't really
am waste much time with playing against
the deep bone probably just be five and
c6 get ahead with the pawn b5 c6 Queen a
for this kind of moves but ok queen bee
three and rocky one that's not bad at
all
yeah more than more than one good way to
play
yeah whoo kid hmm yeah I'm going for the
pressure against five it's um I had this
idea with b5 Queen a 4 and so on but I
wasn't sure that I wanted to allow after
let's say b5 Queenie for Bishop to d3
this seems some wait wait for a moment
yeah it's okay it's okay i was i was
briefly am worried that push-up
defrocked if all the roxy one is not
protected but there are no tactical
opportunity that thing for black okay
take here
yeah well maybe now the rook is some
away from the C file where the pawn will
emerge well looks looks quite clean
they're still this weakness on d5 and
well after the bishop trade it's very
hard to to protect you five even
yeah i can i can take d5 I wonder what's
more precise 25 million yeah yeah that's
okay 25 up 25 it's very good oh he's
writing me miss click he wanted to play
rookie five yeah Rock Lee five is a bit
tougher but not much of a difference i
can play c6 and we'll win with the
Suppan yeah well what to do now I want
to just get attacked the beep on cam he
cannot defend it only with rock v8 and
this is really very passive yeah all
that one okay
oh come on this is this is this is good
and easy just push the pond the rookies
behind the pass up and they're also have
four against three on the King side so
this is rather easy yeah put the rook
behind the pawn he can cannot really
avoid this losing king and porn and game
I play G for this is always useful in
this type of structure as it controls f5
at age five and then pushing the pawns
now okay well but what to do first h4
yeah probably h4 h5 f form this is okay
yeah this um even wins bit more space
black resigns yeah he resigned I'll just
push the pawns it's not much he can he
can do about that and um yeah it really
came down to a difficult opening this is
ambitious maybe it's still playable but
already slightly ambitious if you are
compared to the gruene fraud it's just
the missing temple and here it's tricky
maybe you should take on on sea foam I
was intending 95 this is interesting the
problem is I cannot really take here
because of Queen a for that and the long
diagonal and this this pin is too too
badly ya hear this um maybe maybe night
takes I don't know well this this Lee
really leads to a problematic position
from the tirage the bishop 105 does not
belong belong there at all it doesn't
contribute to the position and it
doesn't it does not protect d5 if it
doesn't increase any pressure it's just
a useless piece and after castles Bishop
e3 year I'm covering the pawn and
there's no way to get it back simply
after after that I just have covered the
pawn and then I'm winning you can only
try for some some desperate count to
play but nothing nothing really
materializes yeah I'm never taking only
for because this would improve the spawn
structure a bit and this is just the the
the cleaner way to play keeping the pawn
on d5 and pushing your own majority to
to get the sepan going yeah pretty
pretty clean game alright thanks for
watching